est ce qui vous arrive de rire toujours
et pourquoi vous le cacher c'est bien
mais en sang
malgré que mon ami graeme croix sont
très très gai parce que les salles se
sont vraiment robin les chansons de
plaisanteries et présenteront au départ
elles sont des plaisanteries mais comme
vous mettez trois ou quatre ans les
écrire à l'arrivée on n'a pas
l'impression que c'est une plaisanterie
bien entendu trésor quand ils sont
terminés c'est très difficile c'est
difficile comme comme travail c'est ce
travail c'est pas
précisément un buisson c'est pas de la
souffrance et de travail tout le monde
sait que servent que le travail
je demande généralement dure paris
quinze jours vous avez demandé vous
parliez d'une chanson avec bob dylan et
qui vous animait cette chanson gilles
écrite en un quart d'heure vous avez un
peu tirer la gueule
ouais je voudrais être dans cet espace
de 7 ce tribut de ce prime ça sérieux
malheureusement je suis dans notre tribu
vous dites je suis de plus en plus dur
en vieillissant ce nouvel album est plus
dur que le précédent
il a commencé il a commencé comme un
papillon il s'est terminé comme un char
d'assaut
donc oui ça c'est vrai ça c'est vrai ça
c'est un char d'assaut qui qu'ils
puissent transpercé tous les terrains
traverse et ça peut être ça va durer
trente ans comme une bande de méchants
sont durs les émois 30 ans comme
l'évoquait pourquoi vous avez alors est
ce que est ce que c'est parce que vous
êtes juif et est finalement nourrit
d'une culture prophétique
mais pourquoi vous avez ce rapport à la
prophétie de la catastrophe
c'est mon métier
pourquoi c'est dans mon sang je ne peux
pas faire d autre surgit pour laver la
vaisselle
j'ai très peu de choses que que je
savent bien faire
la veille les bestioles faire le ménage
et le profit si elle a cette prophétie
de la catastrophe bouhdid à la fois vous
continuez toujours la catastrophe c'est
très facile pour un prophète aujourd'hui
c'est les crêtes des catastrophes
partout partout partout mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai en europe
tout le monde s'est pas résiste cette
idée zf une guerre quelques milles dit
si vous avez un famine quelques milles
d'ici en amérique quand je dis que
l'avenir c'est le maître personne rire
personne résiste cette idée mais ici
quand vous êtes au milieu d'une caisse
catastrophe milieu de massacre tout le
monde résiste cette idée que que
l'avenir c'est la m l'avenir c'est
maintenant c'est le présent et pour
comment vous comprenez cette résistance
d'aidé européen à ouvrir les yeux sont
des grandes artistes les européens sont
des graveurs vous avez le sentiment que
vous pouvez choqué avec le texte le
texte que vous venez de lancer mais
c'est de choquer franchement sincèrement
j'ai jamais cet appétit de choquer les
gens
gg 1 ap exiger un appétit ça c'est de
dire quelque chose que que je peux vivre
avec
avec mon soin respecte sérieusement
règlement à sept mois seulement avec un
impact moi même c'est tout c'est
simplement ça alors c'est cette vision
très très pessimiste que vous avez de
l'homme de l'histoire
en même temps vous dites cette
catastrophe que j'annonce elle a déjà eu
lieu à la à la fin des années 70
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
cherchez à identifier en disant ça moi
je pense qu'un pc mais c'est quelqu'un
qui attend la pluie
et moi je suis complètement oui oui
mouillé mouillé
oui complètement et ceux n'étant pas la
pluie nous sommes dans une catastrophe
les vaut pas la peine d'être d'attendre
la catastrophe
nous sommes dedans ici c'est tout le
monde tout le monde savent ça tout le
monde dans lequel savent que que nous
sommes dans une catastrophe ça c'est le
neuf la ddt
soit c'est là le déluge le déluge c'est
pas après moi c'est c'est avec moi vous
dit il n'y a plus de vie intérieure mais
il ya plus de vie extérieurs dont + qui
équilibre et moi je me tiens à la limite
à la figure à la faille
c'est quoi cette ce lieu où vous vous
tenez à ce que la lumière
mais les gens regardent par la lumière
il n'y a que la lumière la lumière est
la base de tout nous sommes à nous
sommes
noah loin dans la lumière mais mais avec
tes lunettes noires c'est toujours la
lumière signe que la lumière c'est nous
qui invente une idée de l'ombre de de
ténèbres vous croyez au péché oui mais
le dieu pêche avec moi vous dites la
culpabilité
on l'a désavoué aujourd'hui on n'en fait
plus qu'à alors que c'était la seule
c'était l'unique maladie qui permettait
de résister au péché alors vous êtes
pour un retour de la culpabilité
la coupable kabylité c'est un très très
bon mécanisme
parce qu'avec la culpabilité en 5 ans
quelque chose qui n'est pas bon et c'est
encore meilleur et simbad vous écrivait
des chansons vous écrivait des poèmes
vous écrivez des romans pourquoi cette
diversité de d'écriture pour moi c'est
un langue chanson en jeu c'est a pas de
séparation entre les deux aspects
différents de travail
et pourtant quand vous écrivez un moment
donné vous décidez que sur telle texte
vous allez travailler de la musique et
pas sur telle autre non non non non
les textes et la musique sont nés
ensemble ensemble parce qu'il ya une
différence entre un om eric mais ça
c'est une différence technique et c'est
très beau c'est très ennuyeux c'est tout
ce que vous avez dit je crois que j'ai
su qui j'étais mais je les ai oubliés
car ça n'était pas passionnant il vaut
mieux savoir qui on est pas j'ai dit
ouais je vous assure ça fait 48 heures
que je veux dire je suis désespéré je ne
suis pas très attaché à mes opinions sur
tout de moi même